copy moving go
[Music]
this video may contain strong language
as well as graphic images which could be
disturbing to some people viewer
discretion is advised this incident
began in the area of 32nd street and
union hills drive at about three o'clock
p.m
a patrol sergeant was in the area when
he was flagged down by a community
member who provided information about an
adult male suspect who he observed
attempting to steal a vehicle
the sergeant spotted and followed the
suspect who ran away from the area
body-worn cameras are used by all
officers assigned to patrol and several
specialty units per policy they are worn
at mid-torso level and capture the view
of the line of sight from that
perspective it's important to note that
the camera lens is fixed and does not
capture everything seen or experienced
by the officer
when activated both audio and video turn
on
the body worn camera has a buffer of
video without audio for the 30 seconds
prior to activation
this feature is designed to capture
incidents that happen suddenly or an
officer doesn't immediately activate the
camera the phoenix police department
does not currently use in-car camera
systems
as the patrol sergeant began following
the suspect a 911 call came in from
another community member who reported
the suspect attempted to rob them of
their vehicle while they were sitting in
it
here is the audio from that
911 what's the address of your emergency
hi i'm at a
32nd street on union hills
i was at the
and i was sitting in the truck with my
ac on and some guy tried to jump in and
take off with it
and he was threatening me and i don't
know what he took from my truck i don't
know if he took my phone or what but
how long ago
um just like five minutes ago
did he have any weapons he says he does
but i don't think he does
here's a portion of the body worn camera
video from the sergeant who was the
first on scene the suspect ran from the
sergeant and jumped over a fence in a
residential neighborhood
sergeant called for additional resources
and a perimeter was established
of another officer
23 frank he's running
westbound on roseman from 32nd street
patrol officers with the help of police
canines began systematically searching
the yards in the area looking for the
suspect when the suspect started
shooting
this happened a little after 4 o'clock
pm here's a portion of the body-worn
camera from a patrol officer who is
assisting with the search all of the
gunshots that can be heard at this time
are from the suspect
no officers discharged their weapons
until later in the incident on the left
side that's where they were that's built
there were multiple officers in the area
and the suspect was firing in different
directions around the house
officers took cover behind vehicles and
houses officers would later learn the
suspect had broken into a home where the
residents were away
the suspect shot and hit several
vehicles that officers were taking cover
behind
at about 408 pm an officer with a rifle
returned fire at the suspect but did not
strike him
here's body worn camera video from the
officer returning fire at the suspect
we have two officers
that's us that's our dude we get
[Music]
he shooting from for a window
front window middle middle window panel
this officer and two nearby sergeants
then utilized cover fire to help two of
them move further away from the suspect
and to a safer location cover fire is
defined as controlled accurate weapons
fire delivered an appropriate target
with the intent of keeping a suspect's
attention away from the exposed officers
allowing them to move or complete a
rescue or other task
acceptable targets for cover fire are
near the suspect's last known location
and are capable of stopping and
containing weapons fire some examples
include block walls door frames
residential structure header and footers
and engine blocks
here's body worn camera video from the
same officer utilizing cover fire to
move to safety we'll put them in the
door jamb we got a rifle here but we're
going to just suppress the fire and move
west where do you want me to put the
rounds uh
suppression
suppression high okay i'm okay with that
good with that yeah
i have 34 straight rose bomb blocked off
in there yeah just shoot and move dude
put them in that door
uh we'll do i'll do top right window you
do left top top left top you do top left
i do top right okay ready ready go stop
you moving go
here's body worn camera video from two
sergeants who also utilized cover fire
[Music]
uh we'll do all the top right window you
do left top top left top you do top left
i do top right okay ready ready happy
moving
patrol officers worked to cordon off the
area and evacuate nearby residents or
have them shelter in place
the phoenix police special assignments
unit or sau arrived on scene in armored
vehicles
they used a pa system to communicate
with the suspect in an attempt to
negotiate a peaceful surrender
they also utilized less lethal tactics
including tear gas to avoid an armed
confrontation with the suspect and
encourage him to come outside
about three hours after the shooting
began the suspect exited the house with
his hands up
sau detectives provided a ladder for him
to climb down and took him into custody
yep go for it
i'm going to throw you off man i'm going
to slow you closer
um
the suspect was transported to the
hospital for minor injuries sustained
during the incident he was released and
booked into jail on multiple charges
including 17 counts of aggravated
assault against police and residential
burglary
detectives recovered the weapons used by
the suspect inside the home
the officer involved in the shooting has
been with the department for four years
and is assigned to the maryvale estrella
mountain precinct
two sergeants utilized cover fire during
the incident one has been with the
department for 32 years and the other
for 13 years both are assigned to the
black mountain precinct
this incident is the subject of both an
internal and a criminal investigation
which will be reviewed by the maricopa
county attorney's office
conclusions about whether the actions of
the officers are consistent with
department policy in the law
will not be made until all the facts are
known and the investigation is complete
this video was intended to inform and
educate the public about a critical
incident in our community you can learn
about the phoenix police department's
transparency policy on our website